today's one minute monday is just start
I've got a friend of mine who wants to
start a business and she's really good
at what she does but she she doesn't
know what to do next year's know what
step to take who to call where to get
started because of that she doesn't do
anything here's the thing okay you're
never gonna have the perfect plan you're
never going to have the perfect plan if
i look back 12 years ago when i started
this business I would never have guessed
that this is where it would be I would
never have guessed it but I started you
have to get started and even if it
doesn't work out that one step whatever
it is to help you start building
momentum will lead to another step and
another step another step and you'll
find your passion and you'll find a way
to turn that passion into a business but
you need to get started because the way
to be successful I can guarantee you
this the way to be successful is not to
sit on the couch planning all day long
and not taking any action do something
and don't be afraid of it's the wrong
step it's okay do something get started
believe because you're watching thumbs
up below leave a comment subscribe to
the channel I'll see you soon